foreign
early on we tried a workout program
together I held up my end of the bargain
and I felt like she dropped the ball and
just wasn't motivated enough I wasn't
going to be the jerk to keep her
accountable and that wasn't my role you
were just a jerk that was going to walk
around with a wife that you thought was
a lazy bum
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
man hope you're doing well
if you want to be on the show The Single
greatest
I mean ever
just go to Apple or the Googles or the
tubes and look at all of the shows about
marriage and parenting relationships
this is the best ever ever
nobody believes that but if I just say
it over and over I just want it just I
think it's gonna keep happening so if
you want to be on this show we'll talk
about what's going on in your marriage
in your life uh with your kids what's
going on with schools whatever's going
on in your world at work give me a buzz
at
1-844-693-3291 to
1844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask please please please
um man I feel like I'm uh like a middle
school kid like hey can I spend the
night at your house
um but please leave five star reviews
and um sit in the shows that matter to
you to your friends and please hit the
Subscribe button whether it's on podcast
or YouTube it makes a big difference for
everybody thank you so so much all right
let's go to Nick in
hold on before we go to Nick this is
like a hole look at this man we got
millions of people out here in the in
the home audience there's not really
Millions but it's fun to say that all
right let's go to Nick in Orlando what's
up Nick
hey man hey uh just enjoying life how
are you I'm I'm giving that a shot too
man I'm working on it life good yeah and
Life's good uh it was great until you
said millions of listeners and then my
heart dropped
hey don't worry man there's like 17. no
I think we're up to like 26 if I'm being
honest there's 26 listeners I'm good
with 26. that's fine yeah actually I
think it is in the millions brothers
You're Here dudes let's do it yeah might
as well
um ultimately my wife's body isn't what
it used to be and I want to talk to
somebody about it
okay tell me I'm trying not to make a
face
um
all the millions of people listening I
would like to just say it's been fun
having the show and um
I know that that's intentionally
insensitive this this will be the final
episode okay so tell me uh tell me
what's going on how long you been
married so we've been married uh 10
years uh we were uh we were an athletic
couple dating in in our early marriage
and just adding kids and jobs uh that's
just taking the back seat and so
um I want to I want your advice on
having an open conversation I know it's
obvious
um I know my wife's confidence has taken
a toll
um so I want to
I just want to help if I can and hear
your thoughts on it how have you tried
to help already
um we early on we tried a workout
program together
um I wasn't telling her certainly to go
lose weight we took a team effort and I
feel like I I held up my end of the
bargain and I felt like she dropped the
ball and just wasn't motivated enough
and I wasn't
I I wasn't going to be the jerk to keep
her accountable and that wasn't my role
and so you were just a jerk that was
gonna walk around with a wife that you
thought was a lazy bum and no
anyway
um
so so
I'll start the whole conversation this
way you are allowed uh you're allowed to
do whatever you want to
um I don't have one
ounce and I I've got no problem with
um
you being attracted to who and what
you're attracted to that's that's up to
you okay not gonna get any judgment from
me like there's no drinking haterade on
that one okay
um the challenge here is the way you're
framing this
feels like
whether you meant to or not you you had
conditions on a non-conditional on an
unconditional love relationship
and you found them
and this sounds like yes there's
attraction issues but it sounds like
I don't know many married couples who
haven't experienced this and
the maybe the like the image attraction
changes but the total love in the
household the the connectivity all that
stuff doesn't change sure and so
when you say things like she dropped the
ball she screwed up now you're getting
into character issues and my my bigger
concern is
that what what you are going to point
your fingers at is this is an attraction
issue this is a like she's put on 40
pounds or 50 pounds and I don't think
she's pretty anymore she used to be a
hot athlete and now she's not
is
is cover for it's real it's true you're
less attracted to her but it's cover for
I think my wife is lazy I think she I
think she baited and switched me and
she's ripping me off
I got you I think I'm embarrassed when
she wears certain things out in public
because I have an image that I want to
does that make you see what I'm saying
tell me if I'm I'm off or if I like and
here we're already in it so just be
honest
tell me where you are there
no they that all Rings true
um I I I I don't think that she's lazy
and I think that she wishes she had more
time
and more effort or more self-motivation
um to work out and to take care of
things
um
I
yeah I'm still processing I guess
um
I think that
ultimately I don't think that I've set
that condition
um
that you stated but I don't think
let me say it this way most people
unless you're a like just a truly evil
person you're a psychopath or you're
just like a lame like loser
very few people look at
their their just for this example it
their wife in this example and say
you've gained too much weight you
disgust me
I'm not like I I'm grossed out by you
like that that level of vitriol is is
rare oh that's rare but it's not common
sure what's way way more common
is your wife knows you don't think she's
pretty anymore
you don't cut glances at her anymore you
don't give her hugs anymore you keep the
lights off he and so it creates an air
that y'all are sharing you're both
breathing this where she might not be
able to put her finger on it but she
knows
you're out
gotcha and it's very very hard to like
um
you can only be who you want to be when
you've got us a group of people
supporting you walking alongside you
that you know have your back and only
then can you repel off the side and go
do great and wonderful and crazy things
and that can be as little as
hate I'm I'm clearing the deck for you
an hour a day and not followed up with
so you can get some gym time in it's I'm
gonna clear an hour a day because I see
how hard you're working and I love you
more than life itself
and I Mike for the next 60 days I'm
going to give you an hour of your life
back I'm gonna do all of bedtime I'm
gonna do all the dishes I'm gonna come
home with dinner
and you're thinking I'm super busy I
work full time she
that's what support and context feels
like yeah not hey we need to get a
workout program together because she
knows right she she knows you don't like
her or she knows you don't think you're
she's beautiful right that makes sense
yeah and you don't think she's beautiful
on both like both physically and
she's just not she used to be doing this
but she just not cutting it anymore
and I know that sounds so harsh to hear
that out loud but that's where we are
right right
um
so is there are there any I guess I'm
looking for practical and sensitive ways
to even talk about it is there anything
to talk about
um or is there's just a simply a lead by
example and just keep an open cut we
keep an open conversation with our kids
about good and bad things to eat and
taking care of our bodies we've we've
established that is there anything more
I can do besides just opening time up
through the day and and I can I can
practice that I can do that
um is there is there anything else I can
add to that I think you need to do some
really deep soul searching
about
um
whether you're in this marriage or not I
gotcha and
I can't tell you man more times than not
do you do you have somebody else no I
don't is there somebody that you work
with that makes you smile and laugh a
little bit more or is it pretty hot
nope um I'm not there's not a specific
woman there is a there's a I'm honestly
I'm jealous of the dads or husbands that
have the fit wives
um because I see their motivation or
maybe even like obsessity
um to a full Obsession of obsessity is a
new word yeah congratulations thanks
um just to a fault and I I don't want to
swing that pendulum too far to where
it's on in an unhealthy habit
um just looking to to improve all of us
I think you need to be very honest with
your wife
okay and I think the conversation is
about you not her
okay
and I think the conversation begins with
I
am struggling with physical attraction
I'm struggling with the fact that I've
created a house where you're so
exhausted and you're so fried and you're
so out of gas
um
that you've got no space and that's on
me
and I'm sorry that like this is not the
moment you go to and you've let yourself
go and you're doing these things then by
God she's got to defend herself oh yeah
yeah but checking out of the
conversation and I guarantee you you've
got your issues mm-hmm right yep
um
if I'm super honest dude there's
something you're not telling me what's
the what's a bigger what's there's
something underneath this and here's why
like I said every couple every couple on
earth goes through weight Transitions
and fluctuations and you have kids and
all hormones change every and get busy
at work I've put on weight
I've worked with with guy like during
the book writing process my eating has
gotten bananas and so I use it as a
lifting face but I've put on some weight
okay I just have it's a fluctuation and
so that's normal that's a part of you
can see it if you go look on the
thumbnails of my shows you can see I've
put weight on my face like I've just
gained weight
um and I'll go through another phase
whenever I'm done and I'm back so
there's an ebb and flow to all
relationships there's something
underneath this what is it man
I I don't know that there is
um
so your wife is perfect in every way and
you love your life you love your sex
life you love your intimacy life you
love laughing and playing it's just she
just isn't pretty anymore
foreign
that's what I'm aware of I don't know of
something underlying and there could be
I just I don't have that answer for you
um I'll I'll do that soul searching to
find out but I just don't know okay
um
I think you need a season of repentance
for for with her for one big reason
she has gotten the message loud and
clear you don't like her you don't
approve of her and that's got to stop
either either that or you gotta leave
man because you're being cruel
no and uh yeah and it's all unspoken I'm
I'm I'm
I know that she senses that I know that
she's unhappy with with where she's at
too and and so I agree with you
um how
how practically can I open that
conversation up without offending her
you're offending her by
your whole your whole life with her is
an offense and so I would say that ship
has already sailed there's going to be
tears in this conversation there's going
to be frustration there's gonna she's
gonna be pissed off at you like all
that's gonna happen so you can't avoid
that what you can do is speak about you
about what you're willing to do to
create a world where she feels safe and
feels loved and feels like her her
relationship with you isn't contingent
on
um caloric intake and only then can she
say I want to make some changes too
like my buddy Sal the Stefano's like you
can't hate your body into long-term
change right and you can't hate your
wife into studying harder or you can't
hate your white or be grossed out by
your wife until she gets in better shape
that's a recipe for a nuclear explosion
understood okay and so do you see what
I'm saying like this this conversation
is about you yes it's going to be you're
gonna have to be honest
I'm I strong I'm struggling with with
the traction here I'm also struggling
with the fact that I've created a world
where you don't feel safe anymore
yeah also you're gonna have to make
peace if she says I think I'm beautiful
yeah and this is how I am and this is
who I roll yes I used to be a runner or
a karate champion or whatever that's not
my world anymore I got two little kids
now this is my world and then you are
gonna have to look at her in the eye and
say I love you to the moon and back or
you gotta go right
right because you got you also got two
little ones that you're teaching hey by
the way this is what love looks like
and love looks like silence or love
looks like
or love looks like are you sure you want
to have another bowl of ice cream honey
or why didn't you work out today
that's that's they're picking all that
up man they're picking up all of it all
of it all of it all of it all of it
and as somebody who spent a lot of my
life walking alongside people with
disordered eating challenges man it's
just a wrestle it's just man it's just a
mess
you have to own the person you fell in
love with
and that you looked in the eye and said
I'll be with you forever no matter what
[Music]
and
attraction comes and goes feelings come
and go that's part of it
but you're gonna have to decide whether
you love this woman or not then you got
to plug it in there
all other healing and weight loss and
all that other stuff comes after
I'm not going anywhere and I will love
you for now and forever
[Music]
that's the only platform long-term
healing
can can be anchored into we'll be right
back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode's sponsor betterhelp
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is
life-changing stuff but I'll be honest
it's not easy these are new skills that
we all have to learn and therapy is a
great place to practice these new skills
and that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go to the City of Angels
and talk to Sarah what's up Sarah
hi Hi how are you good what are you
doing
um I am just hanging out with my dog
who's choosing to be
um super Restless right now of course I
like how you have personified that dog
way to go yeah he is making choices that
are
so good all right so what's up
um I'm calling because I've had a lot of
thoughts about this thing in my life and
I feel like uh when I found your show I
thought you'd be a good person to ask
and
um so my thing is
I feel like I'm having a lot of trouble
coping with my singleness
and I'm just looking for some maybe some
New Perspectives some advice or
something tell me about it so I've been
single now for six years I'm 34 and
basically the whole time I've been uh
dating so and that's like only dating
through friends
um people I just meet out just you know
different different places
and it's none of them have come to
anything and I mean I'm talking like
80 dates over the years like 100 I've
lost count
and
I feel like I'm starting you know I
really want a family I really want kids
and as the years are like going by I'm I
feel like I'm mourning something that I
haven't even lost yet you know
yeah I know you have you have
I think I think grief is perfect right
now
the thing you don't have is this picture
that you had created for your life
right and it's it's
um
I think we all do that whether like I'm
gonna make a hundred thousand bucks but
I'm 35 or I'm gonna have three kids by
the time I'm like we've we create these
pictures and they kind of come from all
over the place our experiences what our
dad said our mom said our friend said
and they we create these pictures and
then you wake up and there's this little
churn
in in your body that's trying to always
solve for that picture that we got
and it's like the the
anxiety alarms really just start ringing
in louder and louder it's like you're 33
you're 34 Sarah and if you get pregnant
at 35 they drag you into the geriatric
wing and they're like all right you're a
thousand years old now and right so you
have all and that's nonsense but you
have all this all this this undercurrent
in your body is trying to solve for this
picture you had and
the picture changed and so I think it's
really important to sit down and and own
that reality right just choose reality
at this moment I wanted to be married I
want to be in a long-term relationship I
wanted to have one kid and another on
the way
and I don't I think that's important
is that scary
I mean it is but I think like
I think that's what's causing so much
like unhappiness with it
which is so annoying because it's not
conducive to actually like meet anyone
because you feel worse about yourself
you
um
I don't want to come off as like
desperate you know
um and then you start overthinking it
that's what anxiety is the worst man it
just spins on itself
and I I have anxiety issues like of
course so for
the last year and a half I started
taking Lexapro and it has helped I mean
tonight and day is so much better but
you know it's it's always still there
and it's always something I have to work
on and be
um aware of and
so when it's yeah yeah so
what
most medications do
um and I don't know how long you've been
around the show but it
most medications turn the alarms way
down
if you think about it like your
kitchen's on fire
it turns the smoke alarm way down it
does not put the fire out in the
building
right right yeah yeah and so it does
allow you to think and to move and
actually go talk to a counselor and to
get back with your friends and start
getting back to okay I can function now
but we have to function in creating a
life that's not on fire
right
and then over time not every situation
but often the alarms go off because
there's no more smoke because it fires
out
and then you got to figure out what the
damage is and get that taken care of and
then you're on to on to the next
when you look back across 80 or 100
dates
if you had to just say one or two like
this is why this isn't working what
would that be
um I feel like what would happen is
um it was always something like three to
five days so it was always usually get
past the first date most the time second
date yeah usually that was like you know
we have a good time and then third date
is when I get the you know third fourth
fifth it's the um
I feel like nine times out of ten it was
them telling me that you know um
either it would tell me to my face I
mean I got the whole flu or
um they would text me or they would just
stopped talking to me goes to me
whatever one of those but we would
communicate like
I'm not interested anymore and this only
started happening like
since my last relationship ended you
know
um
I feel like I was in that relationship
for four years and
before that I feel like I I didn't
really have that much trouble but why
did that relationship end
uh he cheated on me okay
so hold on let me sit there for a second
the worst part about somebody shooting
on you I think
is not that you feel duped and stupid
and that you lose trust in somebody else
I think the most disorienting thing
about somebody cheating on you is that
you lose trust in you
foreign how did this happen how could I
let this how come I didn't see this how
could I create a world where he felt he
had to whatever you start taking all of
it
and people will
lose the ability to take a firm step on
the sidewalk in front of them because
they've lost faith in themselves they
don't trust themselves anymore
and often healing is not finding it
super trustworthy new partner
it's learning to trust yourself again
and how how do I do that
you gotta own the fact that somebody
cheated on you
sit in it for a minute and grieve it not
just be pissed off and try to go like
out and solve it and oh I'm gonna
I am a good person and yeah I got duped
I did
my worry like I I totally get what
you're saying and I think my what I was
like thinking about was that um
or the thing I was worrying about
because I have so much anxiety all the
time that
I am so hyper like looking for anything
any sign to show that they will like be
like my ex that I feel like I'm it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah and because you know what I I can't
say that there were that many that I was
like oh man that was really the love of
my life that like got got away or
something you know like
but I I guess I'm just kind of like is
because people love to say like oh you
attract a certain kind of person
um so it's like this also this worry of
like oh I'm attracting these people who
actually are gonna hurt me or feel like
they're gonna hurt me and
this is you playing control defense
after you got hurt
and this huckiest thing about healing
from hurt and relationships is the only
path forward is vulnerability
the only way
you meet somebody
who's going to be worth your time for
the rest of your life
it's for you to make yourself vulnerable
enough that they could hurt you
again
and I know that sounds insane
no I I go here what you mean it I think
I think the problem with that is that as
I've gotten older like the way I meet
people like single people is mostly
online because that's just the easiest
like they're everyone's everyone's
paired up like or you know the days will
the dating pool is much smaller and I
think it feels that way it feels that
way and yeah loneliness like the
physiology of being lonely
not just romantically but with friends
too and I'd be willing to bet you money
that
that's a part of this also
is you just it narrows it literally
Narrows your vision of field
to where you can only see caustic
outcomes
it makes everything very very scarce and
it makes you say things like everyone
and always and never
that's what loneliness does because your
body recognizes when you're lonely
you're in danger of being dead
and that's ancient technology right it's
old wiring and that's why you're anxious
all the time
and it sounds like if I let go right now
if I open my hands and just started
hanging out with a bunch of girlfriends
around the house
I started a bowling league for God's
sakes
I put the stupid phones away can we just
do this acquaintages
is the app thing working
um no no and so what if we just didn't
do that for a minute
yeah it's been on pause okay awesome but
did you fill it with something else did
you start going to poetry readings or to
gymnastics class or to jiu jitsu class
or something did you put yourself in
situations where you have to be around
new wackadoodle human beings yeah yeah I
do I try I do try I do try and give me
an example give me an example
because I don't
give me an example
oh my gosh have you seen people at
Planet Fitness not in like I worked out
at Planet Fitness I know but it's not
like that but
people have the craziest workouts there
listen
that's not a great place that's where
people go with their headphones on and
they judge one another
I'm talking about a place where you have
to interact with other people be on the
same team be on the same and with the
same idea be learning something new
growing together that kind of thing in
the past yeah I I have of course tons of
that it I think covid has really thrown
me off because there was a long period
of time we weren't really allowed to do
anything in groups right and especially
in La you know they they really like
things were
um closed or not functioning for a long
time and
so I think now you know
um things are really starting to like
open up again and people are meeting up
again but you know there's
but that that that's why I stopped and
that it's it's like yeah you're right I
should but but let's get back in real
quick Sarah
one year turned into two years and two
years turned into three years and now
we're going on year four
and I've been in LA
and
Down by Hollywood I've been in La
several times and it's wide open right
now
what what do you mean like you can go
you could go right now and sign up for
anything you want to go sign up for oh
right right you're right yeah but I want
I want you to see the common denominator
here we're not going to sign up for a
cooking class or Jiu Jitsu class or
Spanish lessons or poetry readings
and that it's just so we can try to meet
somebody
what we're gonna do is look in the
mirror and say I'm freaking Sarah and
I'm 34 and I'm awesome and I'm gonna
start doing things that I love with
other people
and some of that's going to be
uncomfortable and so that's going to be
me getting out of the house
all of it's gonna be me getting out of
the house I'm gonna put the phones down
for a bit and I'm not saying I know man
my I got family members who've been
married because they met people online
I've got some of my best friends in the
world I'm not saying that's all bad and
wrong what I'm saying is in your case
it's not working so let's try something
else and
social anxiety all the The Angst you'll
feel the only way to heal is through it
even if you go see a counselor for it
they're gonna it's gonna walk you
through exposure therapy limited doses
until your body begins to realize I'm
safe
and that guy that guy cheated on me
four years I gave that guy and I thought
he was gonna be my forever guy and he
cheated on me and now I don't even trust
me
my body doesn't trust me
and we're going to slowly practice human
relationships Again by getting back with
people and getting back with people and
it feels like I was saying earlier if
you take your hands off of the wheel
like the dry like I've got to be married
now like my clock is ticking
um it feels like if you open your hands
and relax that that feeling to I'm just
gonna make Sarah the most awesome person
who's ever lived
and I'm gonna be generous and kind and
fun and I'm gonna go do fun fun stuff
it feels like then I'm never gonna meet
the guy
but the data would say in your world
those other things haven't worked so
let's try something completely different
that's going to create the life that
Sarah wants to live at this point does
that make sense
can I tell you something
there's not something wrong with you
you're not all screwed up or broken or
messed up or somehow dysfunctional
foreign
I'm sorry that guy hurt you
I just away like I grew up I think like
I you know I think it was that thing
like
I was attracted to someone who was gonna
hurt me like and I ignored all the signs
um and you know until it happened or I
found out it happened and
um so I feel like I already had trouble
trusting myself and then
you know having that happen it's like
you know I was already trying to repair
something and it just got more broken
and and you hear that line
um it's not a line it's actually true
that we marry our unfinished business
if we had a dad that doesn't talk to us
we're gonna find a guy who doesn't talk
to us so we can get that guy to talk to
us and so we can finally close that Loop
the only problem is that guy doesn't
talk to us either
and our bodies start hollering and
screaming at us
so when you hear me say you have to
practice something new you've got to do
something new
you have to teach your body
over time
dad didn't talk to me because something
was wrong with him not me
dad would forget to pick me up at school
and I would sit out there until five or
six o'clock at night
because he was too busy not because I
was unworthy
and you've got to teach your body that
your new relationships aren't for
solving Old Wounds they're for creating
a life that you want to live moving
forward
when you can get there it's a powerful
powerful reframing physiologically
psychologically spiritually the whole
kit and caboodle
and you can move forward in a whole new
trajectory
so my challenge to use this Sarah don't
give up on Sarah Sarah's pretty awesome
Sarah's been through it Sarah probably
could spend some time with the counselor
I think that'd be important and on the
line I'm missing you a copy of own your
past change your future my book like and
that's it's just what I'm talking about
here this stuff happened
what are we gonna do next
and then I want you to be serious about
writing down here's what I want in this
next season for 2023 I'm Gonna Learn
kickboxing I'm Gonna Learn
uh I don't know how to roll sushi rolls
I don't know what you're gonna do in Los
Angeles but I'm gonna take a puppetry
class whatever I'm gonna do those things
and I'm going to become the best version
of me I can be and I'm going to open my
hands up
because that's the only way somebody
else can slide their hand in a whole
mine as if it's open not if it's
clinched up and by the way I threw some
shade at 24 Hour Fitness for Planet
Fitness whichever one I worked out there
it's fine those places are great but
dude
some of those workouts people are doing
there in incredible we'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show what you'd like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we are back let's go
actually I'm calling an audible
you're just
producer extraordinaire I know what are
we audibleing to we started the show
this series with a lightning round and I
thought it would be a great idea to end
it with a lightning round is that just
because you want to listen to that music
that's it
yeah every time it comes on like it
reminds me of my uh big hair acid wash
Jean mini skirt days that's literally
what you're wearing right now underneath
the desk
you guys have no idea when she stands up
it is all flowy denim I should wash mini
skirts
anywho
what are we liking running here I found
some questions about married sex
these are some myths that I want you to
bust
can we do that
yes but I did promise my wife I would
yes
yes but I'd promised my wife I wouldn't
talk about us
you don't have to all right let's do it
all right Hello whoa cue the music back
I'm not ready
yeah I can't I have to have this
otherwise it doesn't work
ah jeez
all right question one
scheduled sex isn't Fun ah it's so
stupid here's uh when you add a kid or
two kids and a job promotion and two
people working at home
unscheduled sex is sex you're not having
right it's not having you're not having
it so
schedules I think scheduled sex can be
more fun because you put on the calendar
you know it's coming you start thinking
about it you can start planning for it
you can start fantasizing about you can
start daydreaming about it you can start
hinting about it yeah it's completely
false completely false
to quote
um Dr frankenfurter from The Rocky
Horror Picture Show and Tissa patient
that's probably the oldest thing you've
ever said I know but go ahead no
anticipation's got a whole thing about
it antis
anticipation patient
[Music]
that's cool oh that's what that you have
that tattooed on the back of your arm in
Old English I just didn't I never could
tell what it meant but now I get it I
get it that's cool
right next myth let's do this next
question busted
wedding night Sex Is Wild
[Laughter]
oh
so it's been a minute since I looked at
the data but I was astounded actually at
how many couples don't have sex on their
wedding like it's
such a wild it's a period at the end of
a long long sentence right it's a it's a
big party there's family everywhere
there's a lot of detail there's a lot of
stuff going on you're eating all it's
just a lot and so a lot of couples
have this they they fall asleep they go
home and like hey dude can we do this
tomorrow
um and then there's this sense of we did
something wrong or we failed our wedding
night or I failed her she filled me
whatever the thing is and so
um I think the important thing about
honeymoon sex and wedding night sex and
all that is is let's just have that
conversation let's don't go into it with
mixed matched expectations I think this
is going to happen this way and I got a
disco ball out it's hard to DJ for the
corner of the hotel room and then
somebody else just comes in like dude
I'm going to bed so that's what I think
about that
the whole DJ thing in the corner is
really weird yeah I know I just made it
weird I didn't mean to
all right I
can attack the most
banal thing you can't I'm sorry it's a
gift you have it's a gift all right your
spouse will automatically know what you
like
listen this is a cool thing about being
married is your spouse becomes mind
readers they can just look at you and be
like I know what he's gonna be into
tonight or I know what she wants me to
wear no no
the greatest
um
Hollywood has given us this fantasy that
you just meet somebody and they're like
and then they're a puzzle piece and they
complete you and they know all the
things that you're into and not in tune
for just how long and with just the
right of pressure stupid it's wrong talk
about it say your needs out loud it will
never cease to amaze me how many people
have created humans with somebody else
but they can't say hey I really like
this in bed or I want to try this or I
actually used to really like this and I
don't like this anymore instead of just
hinting or kind of Shifting your body
away because that makes somebody feel
like oh they're rejecting me or they're
super into this just causes it just say
it just say it and if you don't know how
to say it start the conversation like
this I don't know how to say this
foreign
sex is boring
I think I
no I think it's completely false uh I
think it's as boring as you two decide
you're gonna allow it to be
I also think that there is a place for
uh boring married sex there's a place
for just hooking up there's a place for
um
like just to release just a let's
reconnect and then there's a place for
elaborate dramas and weekend getaways
and let's let's see if we can get all
the popcorn ceiling to fall down around
it like there's there's places for both
of it and I think that when we we get so
focused on each individual sexual
encounter and by the way this also isn't
just like we're doing it in orgasm the
sexual encounter sexuality sensuality
eroticism as Esther Pearl says
it's it's the air that you share it's
the way you communicate with each other
the way you touch each other the way you
brush by one another the way you say I
love realistic thank you and so we when
we distill it down into are we doing it
and did you have an orgasm or did you
enjoy man you you lose all of the spirit
and all of the um
engagement all the life force in it if
you will
um
and so no man married sex can I I
contend that Mary's X can be
the best sex the best
place to fall into if you will that
because you're anchored into something
um I could I I think it's it's better
than all other kinds of encounters
all right husbands are always in the
mood
uh actually I
this surprised me as a young married guy
um
talking with young couples
especially women who would say I have
geared myself up for this sex crazed
Maniac who's always going to want to be
doing it who's always gonna like like
excuse me sex XXX and then my husband
gets home from work and he just like
wants to chill out and go to bed and
especially Young
married couples they experience this as
rejection like there's something wrong
with me because I've been told that he
just wants it all the time so the answer
is absolutely not everybody's got
different
um
uh
everybody has different
um seasons for when they want sex or
they don't want sex or they want touch
they don't want touch so no the idea
that every man just wakes up every
second of every day being like I want to
do it I want to do it want to do it not
true all right next question you can't
get the passion back once it's gone
can you elaborate on that
um I think from what I was reading when
I put this together it was kind of the
idea of if you go through a period or
where for whatever reason
you're not having sex you can't get that
back it can't change once that happens
that's just where you are no no yeah
okay so no absolutely false one thousand
percent false
um usually when the quote-unquote
passion's gone it it can be for a
thousand Reasons right
um somebody looks differently they're
acting differently they're um been
really busy at work you got two small
kids all of a sudden or you said your
first kid things happen right things are
chaos um you're going through a series
of season of grief you lost your mom you
lost your grandparent whatever is going
on
and it feels like everything's over
and I like to think about these as
Seasons like just because winter comes
doesn't mean Summer's broken doesn't
mean it's failing it's a part of the
cycle there's just Seasons when
um they feel less passionate if you will
we're not we're not ripping each other's
clothes off as soon as we walk through
the door
what it what I see successful couples
doing is they call it out
they say things like I miss you they say
things like
I desire to be with you and I don't know
how to engage it or what is something
wild we could do let's put something on
the calendar let's use the John delone
erotic envelope system which is not real
I just made that up but let's let's
engage each other
um and let's decide we're going to head
back into this season of passion and
sometimes say hey I'm just too tired I
am I'm trying to get this work project
done I've got to finish grad school
um in year two as a nurse practitioner
and during covet like whatever's going
on and that's when that eroticism that's
in your home it expands to not just
doing it but it's about human touch and
it's about I'm helping her out with the
kids and I'm helping out with the dishes
and I'm going to make sure that I'll
take the kids to school
it's people are leaning in and helping
one another and there's these Seasons
like they talk about trees during the
winter their Roots grow really deep
because they're not having to spend so
much energy
putting out leaves and putting out
flowers it's like that right during
these Seasons when we might not be doing
it all the time we are building deep
deep roots so that when the sun comes
back up
whoa
sorry I went way past time on that one
that's okay I like the analogy on that
one with the tree that's great all right
you can't make yourself feel desire
I think that's true
but there's something you talk about
though yes that may be true that you
can't make yourself feel it but what can
you do what I can control is
the I can control my context I can
control my environment a week in advance
two weeks in advance I can say my needs
out loud hey
I need help around here I'm not sleeping
okay
um I'm coming in really hot from work it
would be a gift to me if you and I just
had 30 minutes to sit on the front porch
and stare off into space together and
just say no like what what do you need
Emily nagoski calls him uh says their
brakes and gas pedals what do I need to
do how do I communicate to you hey these
are breaks for me dishes in the sink a
unmowed yard like a trash laying out on
the driveway whatever the things are I
don't know what they are piles of
laundry whatever it is
um you can create a context so that your
body has permission to oh
and that my friends is where
passion lives
all right you are either sexually
compatible or you're not
no false you learn that's that's the
that's the frustrating thing about
talking about sex with 20 something year
olds and even 30 something year olds is
trying to explain to them probably the
best sex of your life of your married
adult life is going to be in your 40s
and your 50 like you get more compatible
as you get older right as you experience
one another as you become wise as you
get as your relationship goes deeper as
your relationship gets deeper roots and
so there's this idea like I'm going to
be old and wrinkly and whatever hang on
kids buckle up right so no I don't
believe in that we're just not
compatible I believe at the end of the
day we are choosing to not be compatible
and that's a totally different
proposition and by the way I also know
that's super contentious and that
doesn't apply to abusive relationships
but I stand by my statement all right
the older you get the less sex you will
have
um I don't I haven't seen any data on
that
um I don't I don't really know I can
comment on that
um other than to say anecdotally or as
Andrew huberman says anecdata Lee
um I don't believe that to be true there
is come a point when hormones shift when
you're in your you know 60s 70s and like
an 80 like so I don't know how old
you're talking about here but 40s 50s I
don't see I don't
that data may exist I haven't seen it
I've seen it last one husbands and wives
always have the same sexual expectations
so you're asking it with a smile on your
face Kelly what are you really asking
question I mean it's a myth that you're
just
you're just the same thing all the time
out of the bedroom you know that it's
just going to be automatically magical
yes it's just not going to take some
just incorrect discussion and work just
incorrect the number of times I've heard
from couples
um
and again I don't want to over
generalize but especially women who'd
say I just I just have to get into it
and once I start I just got to say I
just gotta go and once I go I'm never
upset that I that I did this but man I
would have just read a book and gone to
bed or I just would have watched another
series and gone to bed if he hadn't
brought it up and then the other side of
it is my God will she just bring it up
once I feel like I'm hounding her all
the time so there's always going to be
this I feel this or I that's where
communication is so important that's
where this idea of how can I meet your
needs as a as an operating strategy and
how can they meet your needs and when
two couples are dedicated to that man
it's really really hard to pull them
apart
um because sometimes what I really need
right now is some space
what I really need right now is some I
need you to like increase my heart rate
sex what I really need right now is just
boring married connection sex and you
may have come in and been like today's
gonna be the uh okay cool I can do that
and you're not gonna hate it and it may
be like I don't really feel like getting
all dressed up
but when we go down that road it's
always fun so I yeah what was your
original question Kelly
I kind of lost it um that you're always
on the same page you always have the
same expectations I would suggest that
you enter into sexual encounters is
assuming you're not on the same page
assume you're not on the same page and
that's gonna impress upon you the need
to talk about it say your things out say
your needs out loud and by the way if
you want to have some Adventure sex you
want to do something wild or have some
um
give each other some heads up sometimes
that can be a lot when somebody's
getting home they just put the kids to
bed they're like all right now we're
good like whoa but if I have all day to
think about it if you've got three days
to think about it if you're like on
Friday we're gonna that's a totally
different proposition
there you go what else is that it that's
it we just solved married sex myths
that's Valentine's busted them that's
our Valentine's shows right there Happy
Valentine's
[Music]
Happy Valentine's Day America is that
how you say that that sounds so absurd
when I say it like that
I feel like I should do push-ups and an
eagle should fly across them like
whatever
I'm glad that's not happening exactly
Happy Valentine's Day y'all we'll be
right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
we're gonna go with a great Pat Benatar
Love is a Battlefield
We Are Young
heartache to heartache we stand
no promises no demands Love is a
Battlefield
man
did not spend a long time on that first
verse we are strong and no one can tell
us we're wrong searching our hearts for
so long both of us knowing
Love is a Battlefield I might get that
as my next tattoo Kelly see you soon